Kourtney Kardashian is worried about  Scott Disick that may be true but that  doesn't mean the 38 year old reality  star and baby mama - Scott's three kids  Penelope rein and Mason Disick doesn't  still care about her ex's well-being a  source close to the former couple tells  ET quote Scott has gone off the deep end  again and Kourt is worried this won't  ever stop but hopes he gets the help he  needs the source also revealed Kourtney  cares for Scott and quote knows he's a  good father but she's had enough and  doesn't want him around their three  little ones until he cleans up his act  no offense to you but no matter what you  do I can't change my life over it this  comes after Scott's trip to can France  where he was spotted drinking and making  out with actress bella thorne and  ex-fling Chloe Bartoli among others  [Music]  you